jokic is third in the nba and assists
per game averaging nearly 11. that's
ridiculous for a seven footer well
you can see we talked about the top of
the program as maxie responds
interesting lineups
maxie he might play upwards of 40
minutes that's for two and he drilled it
tyree smack see the pull-up
over gary davis or gary harris i should
doc takes
dwight out of the game because big guys
have a tendency to pick up fouls again
so he takes them out to be safe to
michael green
in and out trying to bang it off a sixer
still plenty of time for the nuggets to
shoot but reed taking care of business
what a play by reed to get it to maxie
and the sixers lead it
they do so for the first time hey
everybody matt weiner back in our
atlanta studio happy saturday to you all
join us for the american express
halftime report in just a few minutes
time
3d dennis scott the hall of famer isaiah
thomas are on board
taking up and a bunch of rookies and
hanging tough through the first
maxie going against campazo
who is a 29 year old rookie maxie a
little earlier going one on one always
keeping that dribble alive there's the
little pump fake and step through this
is a unit that isn't used to being out
there together
maxi against the much taller to michael
green and he got the roll
max and then here not an easy thing to
do
off of one leg he's third an assist per
game he leads the nba
in total assists as a big man as
maxie out of the timeout right to the
cut sometimes all it takes is just to
see a couple of them go through how many
times on this broadcast that we talked
about wow
another teardrop just watching the ball
go through like that
and i love the fact that he's coming
back leaner
looks like a basketball player instead
of a guy who's had too much of
fun in the summer meantime maxie the
rookie career high 18
challenging jokic and all comer when you
don't want them to get out and run
get some easy buckets because that's how
the rest of them get going
guys like millsap guys like barton
this plays no excuse me plays of the
game check that
with that man allah abdi mark zumaf here
at wells fargo center
maxi got it done that floater i'll tell
you what
what a shot that it delivered that one
to paul millsap
15-year veteran from louisiana tech the
same school as the hall of famer carl
malone as maxie drills the three
he replaces jamal murray
playing in traffic is tyrese mexi give
him
31 points remember andres
nocione absolutely played for the sixers
for a little bit
dude used to just chew on rocks he was
so hard
37. keith wilkes was what he was first
known as
yes tyrese maxi drains the three
crashing the glass for a sixth
he could play another one i'm convinced
as he drills another one give him
39. still bouncy